this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is checking out
the firearms from the tactical shooter
rainbow six siege a rare sighting of the
cz-75 automatic oh no let's pause there
what the heck
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army muse museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to genre
oh god
geez
first weapon up is the c1 not called the
sterling technically it isn't a sterling
i suppose because it is the canadian
variant of what we tend to call the
sterling submachine gun although the
patch it machine carbine to give its
original designation that's possibly
because of legal reasons because the
sterling company still exists first
impression of the 3d model is pretty
good although they always remind me of
return of the jedi because that was the
version of the sterling that was used
for the return of the jedi stormtrooper
blasters i keep staring though at the
rail on the top because as far as i know
the c1 did not have a rail like that at
any point in its real-world existence
and that thing looks like i made it
it doesn't look very robust it's not
like a weaver rail or a picatinny rail
or anything it's just a sort of flange
and i wouldn't necessarily trust
clamping anything to that certainly not
an optical sight it needs to retain zero
it kind of comes prepared for the
inevitable tedious tactical upgrades
that modern shooters must have but
really this ain't a modern firearm this
is the 1950s design 40s design and it
doesn't really sit very well with the
universe of rainbow six not really sure
why it is i'm guessing the operator in
question is canadian
okay we have an ar but importantly it
says ar
15.50 or 50 because this is in fact a 50
caliber ar15 this isn't a fictional
variant this is a real thing and the 50
caliber round we're talking about here
which quite a short round to fit in the
receiver of the ar is the 50 beowulf a
suitably sort of macho name for a
ridiculous
overpowered cartridge with an absolute
ton of recoil and pretty much no
tactical applicability so of course a
natural fit for a realistic first-person
shooter
um sorry i'm being excessively snarky
today here's the 50 in action we have
got
some accessories on here and in this
case that big tank slash barrett 50
style muzzle break probably makes some
sense if you're prepared to take a big
heavy 50 caliber ar into battle why not
have the brake on the end to tame that
recoil we're not talking 50 bmg recoil
here but it is significantly more than
556 or even 762. a quick word on
tools i think siege deserves some credit
for the destructible environments and
the way that you can use in this case
fire to break through to breach
breaching is a huge aspect of special
forces swat tactical action and it's
something that was limited in the
previous games and they really took it
to the next level with siege so
definitely um
credit to you there something we've
noticed before in this series is a
phenomenon that's known in the real
world of firearms as height over ball
where you have a sight mounted very high
above the ball the hole through the
middle of the barrel of course and
because you're looking through the sight
your view of the target is clear but
actually your barrel is below the level
of the wall fence whatever it is that
you're shooting at and we see that
replicated quite faithfully in most
modern shooters i would say but not here
curiously the bullet is actually
appearing from the sight level i don't
know if that's a conscious decision for
gameplay reasons but be surprised given
the sort of attempt to to make this sort
of grounded in realism at least to begin
with it would seem strange to not have
the bullet coming out of the barrel but
it doesn't and we can see that in the
clip with the the burn through
wooden barrier there curious
a rare sighting of the cz75
automatic
oh no let's pause there
what the heck
we've got one here these are not
particularly common they're a very niche
type of weapon for
things like vip
close protection they're really hard to
aim you really need to practice quite a
bit although designers will try to
compensate literally for the recoil with
ported barrels like this one
or other muzzle devices and that's also
by the way why we have a spare magazine
it's flipped upside down and attached to
the front of the gun shown here as an
extended magazine now we just have two
standard capacity
magazines which are standard cz 75
pistol mags with a special base plate
that is a sort of dovetail shape you can
slide them on to the front of the gun
i've often thought with this once you've
fired the magazine in the gun and you
have to swap it over for your spare
that's conveniently stored on the gun
well suddenly you've lost your nice
convenient vertical front foregrip and
you'd have to just hold it like a
conventional pistol the spare magazine
on the game version as we see this
spinning around and it goes upside down
it also looks like that feed lips to
keep the top round in so it doesn't just
fly out and a visible
follower so called because it follows
the rounds up and pushes them up into
the weapon this model doesn't have
either of those it's just a sheet metal
tube and then it's just got nothing on
the end so i don't know if that was
missed well it has to have been i guess
quite intrigued that the
game has chosen not to make use of the
spare magazine attached to the gun in
light of my speculation that that would
actually not be very not be very
practical in real life because you'd
have to remove your empty magazine
fiddle with a little catch to remove the
loaded spare magazine from the front of
the gun that would all be a massive pain
and then you've lost your foregrip so
actually if you're going to use this for
real i think the game's got it right you
keep a spare magazine on there at all
times as a foregrip the other thing is
especially with an extended magazine
it's full as it ought to be it's hanging
off the front of the gun and seriously
affecting accuracy although having said
that it would act as a muzzle weight it
could in theory improve accuracy all of
this is super theoretical i don't think
anyone in the right minds is clearing
rooms with a fully automatic cz pistol
[Music]
diffuser located disable it
another odd sighting for a modern
tactical shooter the dp the degree light
machine gun we featured this before what
on earth is this thing doing in a modern
tactical shooter don't really get it i
mean it's undeniably cool to have
presumably a russian operator using
something as idiosyncratic and
anachronistic just to deploy my word of
the day calendar there as the dp and it
would work you know
no reason why you couldn't use it
although charging through buildings with
a big long heavy gun like that is pretty
daft it is meant to be a light machine
gun needless to say in second world war
there was no red dot sight or anything
i'm not sure what sort of site that's
supposed to be that's on there now if
you were trying to use this tactically
today you probably would try and put
some sort of sight on it so fair enough
at first i i recoiled at the leather
wrapped bits because i i probably
becoming mildly famous for whinging
about things wrapped around guns in
games now um but here it actually makes
a little bit of sense so the leather
wrapped around the fore end or barrel is
actually the sling which seems to have
been severed and has just been wrapped
around and certainly for gripping is
that the rest of it by the look of it
has been wrapped around one of the bipod
legs so that he can use it as a vertical
grip and holding the bipod leg like that
has been an accepted way of hip firing
like machine guns historically not that
you normally would hit fire a light
machine gun but it did happen so an
interesting one but a little bit of a
silly one i think
uh
uh what's that
is that meant to be an f2000 jesus
christ
i am i'm somewhat taken aback by the
sc3000 k and after a short break on the
tom clancy wikis
i have discovered why this looks very
removed from the fn f2000 that it's
obviously trying to be and it's because
this is partly based at least and the
name is taken directly from the splinter
cell games they have kind of merged that
design which was very reminiscent of the
f2000 with the real f2000 it's a bit
uncanny valley because we've got a
couple of these it's pretty close but
every little bit of it is wrong
also interesting are the markings on the
side part of which say 300 blackouts now
the f2000 has kind of stalled a bit
meaning there was no 300 blackout
variant or modular system of parts
developed for it so not only is this
partly a fictional weapon it's chambered
for a cartridge that the real f2000 has
never been chambered for
right this must be our russian operator
friend again with his immaculately
manicured nails oddly we've now got a
strictly prototype as far as i know
mosin nagant derived grenade launcher
with a revolving thing on it
i don't know a great deal about this um
the only place i've ever seen it is on
forgotten weapons it probably only
exists in a russian museum to be honest
so quite a bizarre choice for this game
in terms of how it functions it's quite
fun that they've gone for the bouncing
grenade thing i'm not aware of a
real-life grenade launcher with that
functionality the damage that the round
would sustain bouncing off a wall might
well cause it cause a problem it won't
necessarily bounce the way you want it
to bounce and it might get damaged might
initiate early it might not initiate at
all so that is really more of what i'd
expect to see in doom than in rainbow
six and as you've probably spotted if
you recognize this as a mosin rifle this
is a bolt action so he's putting in a
blank round a grenade a blank round a
grenade but then it's cycling itself
like it's self-loading so really a very
cumbersome awkward system so i can sort
of see why they've fudged it here and
made it work more like a milk or mgl but
with a russian looking skin it's
essentially what we've got here
this curious looking bullpup rifle
ots-03 is a correct designation also
known as the svu it's a dragon of design
the grip looks absolutely enormous and i
suspect that's not right of course being
a ballpark sniper rifle this is this is
meant to be a somewhat precision weapon
so as we see some um mildly nauseating
upside down rappelling there we've got
here a curious optical sight arrangement
a russian sight and it's unusual because
it doesn't have a full frame the intent
there will be to increase field of view
so you're not you don't have a bar of
metal blocking what could be meters
worth of real estate downrange and then
we have this rocking
magnifier what's slightly unusual is
that it's a thermal sight a magnifier
for your reflex sight but it's in this
case also thermal something that is
definitely weird is that the thermal
effect only exists in part of the field
of view whereas at genuine thermal sites
they fill the field of view so i don't
know quite why it's set why it's like a
picture-in-picture view for this it's
just the artistic decision they've taken
another really bizarre choice for a game
like this is this saric not something
i'm particularly familiar with what it
boils down to is this was one of i
suppose many mock-ups for a concept
rifle it didn't get to the point of a
firing design as far as i know it
certainly sort of sunk without trace
0.308 is incorporated in the name of
this version 308 winchester being the
civilian equivalent of the 762 nato
round because this was meant to be for
the export market as a self-loading
rifle or carbine typically what we see
from countries from the former soviet
union when they do that they use nato
calibers because those are the ones that
are increasingly widespread elsewhere in
the world but this is a what you might
call a paper gun doesn't exist other
than as a non-firing mock-up that really
does look like the starship troopers
morita
um but an original design and not
actually a
an existing gun so i'm kind of torn on
it i kind of feel like it shouldn't
really be in the game but on the other
hand it's quite an interesting real-life
reflection of a sci-fi aesthetic
our old friend the much maligned sa-80
in
l85a2 form at least that's what it says
um here is an l8582 and i think you can
see
by looking at it there's something not
quite right about this one what i'm
interested in here is how squat and
foreshortened this thing looks compared
to the real thing although as a ballpark
this is a very squat looking weapon to
begin with it has a full length
20-inch barrel in it this thing at the
very least has a shortened barrel and i
think looking at it the proportions are
wrong too i think the length of the
receiver position of the magazine well
they all look slightly off to me so
whereas a lot of the details look pretty
good some of the basic stuff isn't quite
right perhaps i'm hyper aware of this
because it's a quite an infamous design
and a british weapon but i don't think
i've yet seen a game get the sa-80 fully
right
but it's kind of it's still a treat to
see it depicted nonetheless now i happen
to know slash remember that this was
provided to the sas operator or one of
them which those of you who know the
history of this will will find amusing
because quite famously the sas don't use
the sa-80 as a rule in this setting
hostage rescue slash
counter-terrorism the s80 is perhaps not
the best choice for that application
anyway and it's not what someone like
that would bring the handguard on here
is an impression of the daniel defense
rail system that we see here and this
version that i'm looking at is fitted
with i was going to say the standard
iron sights but the standard
configuration of sa80 has always been
with an optical sight for dare i say
serious use you you aren't going to be
equipping the iron sights in this case
of course it's the base configuration so
that you can then unlock and upgrade
your sa-80 there's an interesting kind
of dichotomy between how the sa-80 is
seen by the sort of firearms enthusiast
community and the military community as
perhaps not not the best in the world
versus the sort of exotic nature of it
the distinctive look the s8 is somewhat
idiosyncratic firstly in how the
controls are laid out and secondly in
how those are used in the standard
british military drills you would expect
anyone to follow the standard normal
safety precautions and drills associated
with the weapon well long story short
the games don't do that and in this case
we see a magazine change we even see the
magazine catch get depressed which is
good and then rather than using the
vault release this catch here
the character is simply
pulling the charging handle to the rear
and letting it go we saw that with um an
ar type
rifle earlier so we should see
clunk rather than
that which is what i think i'm seeing
there the other thing i'm spotting is
another like the c1 very thin anemic
looking sight rail now the s80
obviously does have a side rail it's
this much chunkier
similar shape it's a lot thicker it's a
lot more robust so in other words the
rail is completely different this is
just a bent bit of sheet metal that's
been stuck to the top of the gun this is
a bit more sophisticated than that minor
bit of trivia as well is that this
pattern of rail is actually the nato
standard but virtually no one uses it
what became the nato standard ultimately
was the um picatinny accessory rail that
we see well apart from anything else on
this handguard and on countless other
weapons britain did what it thought was
the right thing in adopting the nato
dovetail and then the rest of the world
the rest of nato went yeah we don't
really like that and it was probably the
right choice to be fair
thanks very much for watching the
firearms of rainbow six siege a long
time rainbow six fan
didn't play as much siege as i might
have liked it's really gone a little bit
wacky since i left it but um very fun to
do nonetheless please join us again next
time here at gamespot also we at the
royal armouries have our own youtube
channel do go and check that out and as
always we'll have links in the
description for ways that you can
support the museum and keep us doing
what we're doing thanks very much
[Music]
you